stanley weintraub talks about his most
recent book uncrowned king the life of
prince albert about books saturday
nights at 8 and sunday nights at 9
eastern and pacific exclusively on
c-span 2.
this week on book notes alan schome
discusses his recent book napoleon
bonaparte book notes sunday night on
c-span at eight eastern and pacific time
washington journal continues
the book is called the secret life of
bill clinton the unreported stories the
author is ambrose evans pritchard good
morning to you sir good morning nice to
be with you let's begin where you begin
in the book you talk about how oklahoma
city bombing how that incident uh
revived the clinton presidency and
you're using the president's words when
you say the term revival he gave an
interview on air force one after the uh
election a few days afterwards he was
relaxed and he said he owed his uh great
turnaround and his fortunes to the
oklahoma bombing and he meant it in a
good in a good spirit it wasn't uh it
wasn't a sort of negative comment but he
said that what it did is it crystallized
a sense in the country that
right wing and republican rhetoric had
gone too far it had fostered an
anti-government
sort of sentiment in the country and it
has sort of precipitated this
this terrorist
movement
why is that incident such a focal point
of this book
well
i think something that hasn't been
reported to the american uh
people is that many of the families have
filed
a lawsuit well a number of lawsuits in
fact against the federal government
alleging that it was a sting operation
or at least at the very least that the
government was negligent and had some
uh
responsibility for what happened perhaps
had a degree of prior knowledge that it
was a broader conspiracy and they
haven't told the full truth
the the families many of them are very
angry
and one family in particular glenn and
kathy wilburn who lost two grandchildren
in the daycare center conducted their
own
private investigation for two years
and they feel that the government
covered up the true story
that it was a broader conspiracy and
that it was probably a sting operation
that went disastrously wrong and they've
not come clean about it our guest will
be with us until the top of the hour our
phone lines are open you can also fax or
email us mr evans pritchard is a
reporter based in london spent some time
here in washington i yeah i did four and
a half years
as the washington correspondent for the
london sunday telegraph and i've now
returned and i'm writing for the uh
about european affairs for the daily
telegraph in london last monday
syndicated columnist robert novak wrote
this piece a sting operation gone awry
and he talks about andreas strasmeyer a
former west german army lieutenant
illegally in the u.s
who is he and why is he important to the
bombing well that's that's a very good
question tim mcveigh
telephoned him
a few days before the bombing shortly
after he
called a rider truck rental agency
and that's how he got drawn into the
whole question of the bombing in the
first place now he's a former german
army officer spent eight years in the
bundeswehr and he told me he'd had
intelligence training
he done some intelligence work in the
german army and he came here
with the intention of working undercover
for the us justice department
and he admitted that to me
so it's quite significant that he should
figure as a character in this um the
extended mcveigh circle he's also been
named by an undercover informant of the
atf carol howe
as
somebody who's stirring up
race war and a terrorist campaign
against the u.s government now with his
background
i find it very hard to believe that he's
a genuine
neo-nazi terrorist which is how he
presented himself i suspect that he was
here on some kind of undercover mission
now whether it was for the german
government
or for the united states government or
both
i don't know i think my own conjecture
and this i can't prove it
is that he was
a joint asset
penetrating the neo-nazi far right
um and there was great concern that they
were escalating their terrorist
activities you devote a fair amount of
time to a lot of the conspiracy theories
that we hear on this network and read
about from time to time in different
publications vincent foster was it
suicide was it murder well i don't
answer that question
what what i say is that kenneth starr's
investigator the prosecutor he appointed
to reopen the the case
came to a different conclusion
he told ken starr after a four-month
investigation that there was serious
evidence of foul play his name is mikael
rodriguez
he went to star he told star what he'd
uncovered during his investigation using
the grand jury
and ken starr looked the other way
he didn't want to hear it he didn't want
to deal with it so rodriguez resigned
went back to california and that is the
only time that he's ever been seriously
investigated after that it was all
damage control so i you know i don't
feel that ken star has the authority
to deliver the report that he's
delivered
i don't think he answers any of the
questions it's just a rehash of the fisk
report which was incredibly weak and uh
he
selectively uses witness testimony to
support his case and it's very very thin
and people who are familiar with the
with the archive of documents in this
case
know that he's just ignored a colossal
amount of evidence and he's ignored what
the crime scene witnesses said
so what is your conclusion on the
clinton presidency so far
in terms of the scandals or in terms of
its general well in terms of this book
well i i would
uh
my conclusion is
that he's a very very corrupt man and um
you know
it's partly a generational thing i think
that the current generation in power
not just in america but in most of the
industrial countries is
is very
has lost its honor code it's lost its
integrity
and bill clinton is the emblem of that
you're right that if president clinton
eludes justice at least it can be said
that his destructive influence has been
checked and checked by whom well the the
the good side of this book is not all
negative um is that the ordinary people
in america have held the line
you know and we've we've seen it with
the families in oklahoma we've seen it
in other people through the book who
resisting abuse of power in their little
corner and perhaps not always
successfully but they're basically
preventing
um
what i consider to be a decadent and
dishonest leadership class
from dragging this country down and
turning it into a banana republic you
know
the ordinary people are the ones who are
going to save america and not allow it
to go the way that other countries have
gone when his democracy has been
threatened by internal decadence i want
to get to call us but briefly give us
the history of why you wrote this book
and who your sources were
well the
i'll go to the sources first um there
are very few unnamed sources in this
book in fact um almost all of it is got
named sources so people can make a
judgment for themselves
and how they want to
evaluate it
you know i first got dragged into this
morass
when i started going to arkansas and
talking to ordinary people there and i
became quite clear to me a lot of very
bad things have been going on for the
last 10 15 years
that it had become a haven of
narcotics trafficking and the more i
looked into it it seemed to me the
political machine in arkansas was
involved
and
there'd been a lot of a misuse of the
criminal justice system people had been
intimidated people had died
the um and i started looking into these
uh issues and i i um
well there was no going back after that
i got drawn right into the middle of it
you also have uh a fair amount of pages
toward the end appendix's a b c so on
and so forth what's in here well
um the first part of documents from the
oklahoma bombing case particularly the
the
debriefing reports from the atf when
they debrief their um
their undercover informant carol howe
including a uh debriefing from the fbi
um two days after the bombing when she
named
strassmar and another fellow dennis
mayhar in oklahoma as having planned to
blow up federal buildings and she said
specifically the dennis mayhanna planned
to blow up the oklahoma
city federal building this is two days
after the bombing she's at the command
center of the fbi in downtown oklahom
oklahoma they never interviewed this man
they conduct over 20 000 witness
interviews all over the country many of
them irrelevant and they never
interviewed the man that their own
government informed told them had
planned to blow up that particular
building
they have a lot of answering to do
the book is called the secret life of
bill clinton the author is ambrose evans
pritchard we'll get a call from battle
creek michigan from our independent line
good morning
yes i think uh bill clinton's getting a
bad rap and so is al gore because
says in the
constitution of the united states that
all people are created equal
how come homosexuals have to pay taxes
but they're not getting any fair
representation i'm a perfect example i'm
suing the company because they were
homophobic
they had the police come and drag me out
of my house
and torture me for 17 hours caller i'm
going to jump in only because we have a
brief amount of time and we're trying to
talk about this book by mr evans
pritchard did you want to comment on
that or have a question sir
and he's being dragged through the mud
by these republicans when they find him
clean they should charge a republican
party for the cost to the american
taxpayer so you're saying because he
supports gay rights he is being attacked
uh by the republicans yes okay
your response well uh
there may be a bit of that going on i
don't know i mean everybody has their
own agenda i can't really answer to that
i mean i have something of a libertarian
streak in me and um
whether somebody's gay or not doesn't
particularly bother me from our
democratic line charlotte north carolina
good morning uh yes
yes how are you doing fine thank you i
i just like to say that
everybody
is a little strange on this waco and the
oklahoma city bombing
i think you should look to possession
for this individual timothy mcveigh and
you might find the answer if you don't
do that you're you're losing the
situation all together
so what what do you mean by possession
i'm not sure i
quite understand the question in the
bible
that's a very personal question i don't
want to get into religious issues really
on this program who published the book
regnary it's a
conservative publishing house in
washington
were they your first choice did they
come to you did you go to them how did
that work uh
actually you know i wasn't really
i wasn't really planning to write a book
i just thought it'd be it was too much
too difficult to do and um
i have a friend who's an editor at
ragnary and he approached me and he
encouraged me every period of about a
year to do it and then my wife weighed
in and said you've got to you've got to
write all this stuff he said you can't
leave the country without putting all
this into a book so she persuaded me to
accept the offer and um so i did how
many books have been published
what the first print run i think it's
about 50 000 which is quite quite a lot
actually and explain this picture when
was it taken and why is that on the
cover well
oddly enough i can't answer that because
i've only just seen it myself um i came
over from london on thursday night and i
never seen the book before they
presented me with a copy and i thought
that's very nice the picture of course
of first lady hillary rodham clinton
whispering into the ear of uh president
clinton uh but was that taken at the
white house you just don't know i don't
i must find out it's terribly negligent
of me not to know but um
we'll get a call from hattiesburg
mississippi good morning to you you're
calling from our republican line yes
good morning
i would like to ask the author about as
i understand that bill clinton will not
reveal his medical records and make them
public
is this the first time that american
president has does not want to reveal
their medical records i understand that
when he first became president that the
doctor in the white house was fired
because he wanted to see what bill
medical bill clinton's medical records
had to say i appreciate your comment
about this that's true the doctrine in
the white house
um
he he was going to give
an injection an allergy injection to the
to the president but he he was asked to
do it and he refused to do it unless he
uh saw the medical records first
um and he was i think fired within three
or four hours of that
um i think it's only in recent american
history that um people have
even thought of
requesting the medical records from from
the president so i don't know whether
there's a real precedent here
um he certainly has never revealed them
what he's done is reveal uh hand over
summaries of the medical records but not
the actual raw documents and one of the
things that i know that the paula jones
legal team want to do is shake loose the
entire
set of raw documents
going back
15 to 20 years
you
in a number of instances
use the term abuse of power
who has the power and who's abusing it
right
well it's it's
it's about it's more than just clinton
it's about the whole um power structure
in the united states but who
specifically
well the justice department
the fbi
the
political class
uh as a whole so when you say the
justice department are you referring to
janet reno and when you say the fbi are
you referring to director free or are
there people in the departments that are
abusing the power well i think they're
people in the department abusing the
power you take the case of carol howe
when she came forward as an undercover
informant
and said yes it's true i penetrated
what appeared to be a bombing conspiracy
uh that has great relevance to the
oklahoma bombing they immediately
indicted her on on with an indicted they
busted her house she was still working
as an undercover informant for the atf
the fbi comes and busts her house and um
arrests her boyfriend charges him and
then they hold over her for three months
the possibility of charges and when she
refuses to to toe the line and shut up
they indict her and then they put her on
trial
and um you know uh she went on trial
last july in or in august and she was
finally acquitted by a
jury in tulsa but that that was an
absolutely disgraceful thing to do to
eliminate somebody who's become a
liability to them
by by what they did is they turned her
cover against her she'd been given all
this explosives equipment as part of her
by the atf where she collected it during
her duties for the atf they knew she had
it
and they turned her cover against her
they said because she had this equipment
she was planning to make a bomb
that's absolutely ridiculous so who's
calling the shots who's telling them to
do this very good question and it
appears that this thing was orchestrated
by the highest levels of the fbi
um fbi counterterrorism in washington
they seem to be the orchestrators of the
criminal
um charges against carol ohio and they
should be held to account for that
absolutely disgraceful but the it was
the assistant u.s attorneys
who actually prosecuted the case in
tulsa and it was a u.s attorney in tulsa
i suppose it's the
eastern or northern district of oklahoma
um
who
must be held accountable for this who
gave the order for that did anyone in
the clinton white house either current
or former cooperate with you on this um
they stopped cooperating with me quite a
long a long time ago why
i think they um
they found that they couldn't really
spin me
from our independent line fort mojave
arizona good morning hi
this is penny good morning good morning
to you
i was calling to um you say carol howell
was the informant for and had such power
how can this happen in our judicial
system here in america i don't
understand how do we know
everybody's saying mcveigh is guilty
i have a total uh opposite belief of
that oh you do
well um i i think he's
i think he was guilty and his lawyer
pretty much admitted that during the the
sentencing
um hearings
uh but
um
i think it's only part of the story
there are a lot of people in downtown
oklahoma who saw mcveigh with a group of
other men that morning
operating in what appeared to be a
terrorist cell
and i feel that the the investigation by
glenn and kathy wilburn and um
and
an oklahoma journalist called john cash
who's done incredible work for the
curtin daily gazette have essentially
sketched
um the outlines of the broader
conspiracy and who might have been
involved and they've concluded that the
bombing was carried out by an
organization called the aryan republican
army
which is the um military wing of the
aryan nations
neo-nazi movement in fact you have a
document here that calls it the white
aryan resistance and it's from the
department of treasury which
supervises the bureau of alcohol tobacco
and firearms how did you get these
documents well they came
a lot of it was
was um
came forth in legal discovery from carol
howe's
criminal trial
uh
some of it came for a little bit of it
came out
uh in mcveigh's
advanced trial it was provided to
mcveigh's defence team in discovery so
basically most of it has come forward in
in um through through the legal process
not all of it there are some things in
there that are still sealed that i've
been able to to examine a few more
minutes uh with mr evans pritchard who's
the author of a new book on president
clinton and his administration
pittsburgh good morning
good morning my name is mary kay
and i'm calling this morning
[Music]
to ask mr uh
sorry i can't recall your name right now
about your background and your
credentials and so um
gathering and writing the information
from this book i didn't catch the
early uh part
right well um i uh
i was the washington uh bureau chief for
the london sunday telegraph i was sent
over here on a on a routine assignment
um i was here for four and a half years
um before that i've uh
i worked
covering economic affairs
in london i worked in latin america for
many years i was the
central american correspondent for the
economist at one point
and i've done two stints in america as a
reporter so i've done seven or eight
years reporting in this country you're
now back in london did that have any
direct relation on this book
well it was a hell of a lot easier to to
write the book and then and then and
then leave um without
and escape all the consequences of it in
the sense that i if i was an american
journalist and i i'm pretty critical of
the american press but i can see
all the constraints that they're working
under
and it's it's quite difficult to
challenge the entire power structure
which is what i've done in this book
it's not just attacking clinton i'm
pretty tough on the republicans as well
you kind of burn your bridges and you
lose your friends and it's very
difficult for an american journalist or
any journalist to write that kind of
book about their own country they can't
continue to operate and function
as a journalist
i mean if i did this in london about the
british
power structure i really couldn't
continue to work there so
leaving sort of made it easier ridgewood
new jersey good morning hi good morning
you just mentioned that the aryan nation
might have been involved in that bombing
and i'm just wondering
um
did they have any any objection to the
waco uh
debacle was it just coincidence that the
oklahoma city bombing occurred on the
anniversary of waco also was larry potts
involved in the investigation of
oklahoma city wasn't he all involved in
the investigation of oklahoma city
wasn't he also at ruby ridge and
at waco and you talk in your book about
uh jerry luther parks thank you
uh
well that's a hard hard question to
answer all of that the
the aryan nations um
probably
had
they didn't like they didn't like the
branch davidians at waco because um
uh
about 40 percent of the people who died
in waco were actually black they were
mostly jamaican um
and there was some of them were jewish
as well and the area nation is very
anti-semitic and very of course
anti-black so but there was a certain
unparalleled interest that they
uh saw the government um out of control
and um
the the in fact that the branch davidian
flag was flying at this at this
headquarters of the
um of this neo-nazi group uh elohim city
so there was some kind of identity with
them and i think tim mcveigh was very
much influenced by by waco but i'm not
sure that some of the other people we
suspect were involved in that conspiracy
that was that was a factor but not the
only factor i think um the a bigger
factor was the fact that one of their
leaders was executed on the day of the
bombing
he's called richard wayne snell
he was executed in arkansas on april the
19th 1995
and i know some of the families feel
that
that probably was the biggest single
um that's why that date was chosen in
our remaining moments how does all of
this connect to the president
well he's
all these have hap things have happened
under his watch waco happened under his
watch it's the worst it's the wounded
knee of the 20th century you know the
the worst abuse of power people in terms
of number of people killed as an as a
result of an act by the government and
he never dealt with it
he
instead of
heads rolling people being brought to
account they went out and tried the
victims and many some of the victims are
now in prison serving very long
sentences on what i think incredibly
flimsy charges and so that set in motion
um the militia movement
is set in motion
to some degree the terrorist domestic
terrorism movement the united states now
suffers from including the oklahoma
bombing and this happened under his
watch although there are there are
deeper forces that have been at work for
many many years that kind of contribute
to this
i'm not sure it would have happened if
paul tsongas had been elected democrat
uh democratic president ambrose evans
pritchard is the author of the secret
life of bill clinton the unreported is
now available
at bookstores by ragnarok press thanks
very much for joining us thank you
we hope you'll join us uh tonight for
road of the white house followed by book
notes and a live question time looking
inside the british house of commons that
can be seen at nine o'clock east coast
time and tomorrow morning on this
program our newspaper roundtable segment
will include jill nelson of usa today
also we'll be joined by white house
director of legislation uh john hilly
and pat choat who was the reform party
vice presidential candidate last year
we thank you for joining us on this
sunday enjoy the rest of your weekend
and have a great week ahead